we have brand-new plot details about one
of the most exciting and highly
anticipated series coming to Disney plus
the Loki series how's it going everybody
it's Warren and ever since we found out
that we were going to be getting an
exclusive Loki show coming to Disney
Plus fans have been super excited to
hear what it's going to be about but of
course
Loki died in Avengers infinity war when
Thanos choked him and snapped his neck
so everybody was wondering what is this
show that is all about Loki going to be
about if Loki died in Avengers infinity
war and when will it take place in time
well today fortunately we have some
answers for you and I'll break it all
down in this video quick reminder if
you'd like a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 be sure to subscribe to my
channel with the notifications turned on
like the video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain to
enter my giveaway I'll be picking a
winner at 500,000 subscribers so one of
the most shocking things about Avengers
in game was when the Avengers go back to
2012 and Loki escapes with the tesseract
now according to the rules of
time-travel that the Avenger stated in
the movie Loki just created an alternate
timeline so obviously this changes a lot
of different things and then at San
Diego comic-con with the phase 4 reveal
Kevin Feige has confirmed that the Loki
series will take place right after Loki
escapes in 2012 in Avengers end game and
although that does give us a little bit
of information about the movie it
doesn't exactly tell us what he's going
to be doing and what he's going to be up
to well today thanks to some production
sources for the Loki series we have
learned a couple of things about the
plot of the show one is that the
tesseract is going to be involved a lot
and is going to be a pretty big part of
the show this makes sense as Loki just
got the tesseract and probably isn't
going to be giving it up anytime soon
and that ties into the second thing that
we learned about the Loki series which
is he'll be travelling throughout human
history but not only will he be
traveling throughout the events of human
history he will be changing major
historical events this is classic Loki
the god of mischief this is going to be
pretty entertaining to see because
although Loki might do some good
changing historical events he's most
likely going to do a lot of bad not
necessarily anything major but he's
going to change things that are going to
benefit him we already knew that he was
trying to rule earth that's what the
first Avengers
was about so lucky going back through
time changing historical events is
probably going to be about making him
the ruler of the planet earth and not to
mention after Marvel's Hall H panel at
San Diego comic-con Kevin Feige did have
a comment about the Loki series in which
he said that this is not the Loki that
we knew from Avengers infinity war this
is Loki from 2012 the same Loki that was
just trying to take over Earth he's not
yet a mature Loki he hasn't gone through
many events that made him into the Loki
that we saw in Avengers infinity war he
hasn't gone through the events of Thor
to the dark world where he loses his
mother and he hasn't gone through the
events of Thor Ragnarok where he
actually does change and tries to help
Asgard so in Loki's Disney Plus show
we're going to see a Loki that is still
not that mature yet and it's pretty
mischievous and villainous which i think
is going to pan out to a great show
coming to Disney Plus where Loki is
changing historical events throughout
human history but again it is important
to note that according to the
time-travel rules established in
Avengers in game changing the past does
not affect the future so Loki is
probably going to be creating a bunch of
different alternate realities and this
is actually very very important to the
MCU because remember these Disney Plus
shows do tie into the MCU they are canon
remember these Disney Plus shows take
place in the MCU so Loki creating a
bunch of different alternate realities
could in fact be establishing the
multiverse
we know that the multiverse is going to
be a pretty big deal moving forward in
the MCU they tried to trick us into
thinking that spider-man far from home
was going to set up the multiverse but
it didn't however we now have Doctor
Strange to Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness so they are going
to be bringing the multiverse into the
MCU so the Loki show is probably going
to contribute a lot to the multiverse
we've also learned that the Loki show
has begun casting so it's well underway
for its release in spring of 2021 so let
me know what you think about these major
plot details that were released about
the Loki series coming to Disney Plus be
sure to let me know in the comments
below and also don't forget to comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
like this video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to the MCU as always thank you all so
much for watching will fall off